mein name ist schon teil kopf ich bin 26
jahre alt und ich kandidiere für die
grünen im wahlkreis freiburg für die
bundestagswahl
die hochburg der grünen liegt im
breisgau im bundestagswahlkreis freiburg
hat die partei vor vier jahren 21,2
prozent der zweitstimmen erhalten an die
damalige direktkandidatin kerstin
andreae gingen 25,7 prozent der
erststimmen
ihre nachfolgerin scheint teil kopf
treffen wir in ihrem büro und in der
freiburger innenstadt
was macht freiburg aus sehr viele
menschen die zum studium nach freiburg
kommen bleiben auch hier weil es hier so
schön freiburg hat eine sehr hohe
lebensqualität
das liegt an einem vielseitigen
freizeitangebot aber auch natürlich an
der natur einer anlage am schwarzwald es
gibt zahlreiche ausflugsziele auch das
elsass ist in unmittelbarer nähe der
kaiserstuhl und natürlich dass freiburg
auch nur sehr sehr junge stadt ja es
werden hier sehr viele junge familien
auch es gibt gutes bildungsangebot gutes
kita-angebot und eben eine renommierte
und forschung starke universität wie
ticken die menschen hier natürlich haben
viele menschen in freiburg ist
ökologisches bewusstsein und sind auch
politisch sehr engagiert es gibt viele
vereine die sich zum beispiel für die
integration von geflüchteten einsetzen
und für eine offene und vielfältige
gesellschaft es gibt viele umweltgruppen
sehr kurze frist für future ortsgruppe
also die freiburger zivilgesellschaft
würde ich schon als sehr aktiv kritisch
und lebendig bezeichnen
warum sind die grünen in den letzten
vier jahren so stark geworden also die
anderen parteien haben glaube ich dass
jahrhundert thema klimaschutz
schlichtweg verschlafen und die menschen
trauen uns grünen zu
nicht nur auf das thema hinzuweisen
sondern auch die politischen antworten
zu geben
für funktionierende maßnahmen für mehr
klimaschutz für die energiewende für die
verkehrswende und wir zeigen auch dass
wir verlässlich regieren können in baden
württemberg führen wir selbst über zehn
jahren jetzt die regierung an und wurden
deutlich wiedergewählt also die menschen
sind auch zufrieden mit grüner politik
und trauen uns eben zu land zu regieren
und verantwortung zu übernehmen was
können andere grüne von ihnen lernen
ich glaube was man schnell lernt wenn
man wie eben in freiburg als grüner auch
große politische verantwortung übernimmt
das man häufig auf zielkonflikte trifft
gerade in ballungsgebieten wo es einen
massiven mangel an bezahlbarem wohnraum
beispielsweise gibt und gleichzeitig
natürlich die politische aufgabe denn
den flächenverbrauch zu reduzieren dass
es einen zielkonflikt der uns hier schon
lange beschäftigt und wir natürlich nach
lösungen suchen zum beispiel wie kant
ökologischer gebaut werden können wir
vielleicht höher bauen um den
flächenverbrauch zu reduzieren
also ich glaube dass man eben dann in
der in der praxis in der konkreten im
konkreten politischen alltag auf
probleme stößt und grüne ziele zu
verbinden mit den großen
gesellschaftlichen aufgaben die es
darüber hinaus auch noch gibt was halten
sie von ihrer kanzlerkandidatin annalena
baerbock
annalena baerbock elektrisiert sehr
viele mitglieder und sie steht für den
aufbruch den wir eben brauchen in
deutschland die schwarz-rote koalition
verwaltet ja seit jahren nur noch krisen
und hat keine ideen mehr für die zukunft
unseres landes die wir aber dringend
brauchen angesichts der großen
herausforderungen der digitalisierung
der auswirkungen der pandemie und der
klimakrise und da brauchen wir
politikerinnen und politiker mit
veränderungswillen mit neuen
herangehensweisen und neuen ideen und
dafür steht annalena baerbock